hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the 1858 uh
not the match but the second match
between paul charles murphy and arnold
anderson the actual match ended by
morphe winning seven games which was
enough to win the match uh anderson
winning two and two games were drawn but
now we have the second match between
morphy and anderson which occurred the
second day after the end of the first
match and it's basically
two of them enjoying uh some chess while
the photographers were you know
preparing everything to take a photo i i
the match lasted for some three hours
even though it doesn't take as much to
take a photo in those days the
photography as i understand it is around
since 1839 officially and since this
1858 technology has advanced somewhat
but you know you still needed at least
an hour to make like a good photo if it
was outside in in noon for example
taking the actual photo did not take all
that much but preparing everything for
the photo did if anyone is a
photographer and is a well-versed in the
history of photography maybe you could
you know link something to us or maybe
write something in the comments that we
can all uh learn from but as they were
preparing to have their photograph taken
they played this match six games of
nothing but the king's gambit and this
is the first game of this second match
uh morphe will be having the white
pieces and uh some of you asked me uh if
there is uh anywhere that is it possible
to see this photo anywhere i couldn't
find it i couldn't find any trace of it
because it's um it was published next
year and it was published in max lane's
uh paul morphy's uh
schizo house that shocked
part two uh it was the cover and well if
anyone has that you know maybe from
their great great great great great
great grandfather uh you know maybe you
can take a photo and and share it so we
can all enjoy it but uh other than that
i don't think this photo is available
anywhere but if any of you do have it i
would also very much like to see it so
you know do do share in the comments uh
but yeah getting back to this game it's
going to be uh really awesome and six
games of kings gambit so anderson lost
the actual match where uh you know the
the winner was decided but now he will
definitely try and you know have his
revenge on morphe trying to create at
least some sort of a brilliancy in this
game he attempts just that so let's see
how it went morphy with the white pieces
opens with e4
we have e5 and like we said all six
games will include the king's gambit so
f4 morphe goes for the kings gambit e
captures on f4 knight f3 and now g5
black plays this move and although i
remember when i first started uh
learning some chess openings
pretty much started with the you know
the open games kings gambit evans gambit
and you know maybe the scorch and some
uh fine gambits uh but the g5 seemed
like a really
bad move for black because you know you
never
you never really do this a week in the
king side lately like this but even
though this was played in 1848 to this
day it stands as the strongest reply uh
from black
to this variation of the king's gambit
and uh you know they they played it just
as well back then so here bishop to c4
by morphy and bishop to g7 uh and
nowadays d4 is considered the the
absolute best here but morphe first
castles uh he says i'm gonna play d4 at
some point either way so d6 by anderson
we have c3 now ready to grab
uh the full center with the d4 we have
knight to c6 uh and now there are a
couple of games um i think last one was
played in 2016 where d4 was played but
morphe plays queen to b3 and it is now
as of move seven that this position has
never been repeated uh again uh the f7
pawn is hanging here so queen to e7
anderson defends it and now morphy grabs
the full center with d4 now having this
beautiful setup here i know what you
guys are considering you guys are
considering knight captures and g5
characters and then bishop captures on
f7 uh sorry about the weird arrow but
this doesn't really do all that much but
it it kind of seems like it does because
for example king e7 bishop captures here
you might think you're to yourself but
why not this is i mean winning for white
well it would be if black did not have
rook captures on g8 that's the problem
and now queen captures and g8 bishop d
for check and the morphe will lose the
queen so
that's the problem of this uh entire
plan so morphy plays d4 grabs the center
as we said and now comes uh knight to f6
by anderson uh you might also consider
h6 here it's um
knight to f6 is a pawn sacrifice which
is very very risky h6 is a boring way to
play this but um definitely a modern
approach and black would be considered
even better here but i will show a fun
line what happens after g4 because you
also have to consider this then we would
have knight to g5 and now queen captures
on g5 but now white can't play bishop
captures on f7 and if kink the e7 now we
simply play bishop captures on f4 and
now the queen cannot remain here and
once the queen moves then we can capture
here because there will be no bishop to
d for check and uh well white will not
lose the queen so here you'd have to
move the black queen we're going to
capture the knight and now white is just
winning here with e5 coming next it's a
a very very difficult position for black
but okay anderson did not go for that he
didn't go for h16 it didn't go for g4 he
played knight to f6 he gives up the g5
pawn
and he wants to start the attack on
morphe with his own king still being in
the center of the board so here knight
captures and g5 by morphe and now
uh you know you might think okay
anderson gave up a pawn he's now going
to castle and he did it to you know gain
some quick development but no anderson
plays knight characters on e4 he allows
the bishop captures on f7 so morphy
plays it we have bishop captures on f7
with check king the d8 and now comes
knight captures on e4 we have queen
captures on e4 and now bishop captures
on f4 so what is anderson's plan here i
mean uh the knight can hardly get into
the game the pawn prevents it from
entering the rook can't really go to g8
the bishop stops it you can't go to here
that the bishop also controls that uh
well anderson uh is truly a madman a
gentleman but also a madman anderson
plays bishop to h3 and now
anderson is threatening checkmate here
and uh morphy has to deal with this
somehow you you could maybe defend
checkmate you could also just grab the
bishop morphy uh decides that grabbing
the bishop is the way to go here you
could also go bishop d5 here just attack
the queen and guard this g2 square but
morphy says all right
anderson let's see what you got g
captures on h3 and now anderson
continues happily sacrificing with
knight captures on d4 and indeed this
second sacrifice cannot be accepted
if c captures then anderson captures
with the bishop and it's game over
there's no square for morphy's king if
you block it we can simply capture it
bishop captures with check rook f2 but
now even queen f3 is enough now we're
gonna win like this and if queen to c2
then we can simply pick up the bishop so
it's completely crushing uh but here
after knight captures on d4 morphy says
dude i'm not going to take your knight
and here uh morphy just played knight to
d2 he just continues develop development
uh there is a tricky way you can uh
completely destroy black here and you
know it's it's a pretty funny line
bishop to g5 check making it really a
problem for the white king to do
anything king to d7 and now queen to d5
and now after knight to e to check the
white king has only one square king to
f2 but now you don't really have
any move with with black there's no way
to continue the attack here and you're
just gonna you know end up being down
material so this is one way to do it
morphe decides to do it um you know in
in in a calm way knights to d2 now
saying okay we can trade queens but
trading queens doesn't really do
anything for anderson because if he goes
for this uh he already sacrificed for
the attack yes he could grab the
exchange here but after rook captures on
a1 rook to f8 going after the bishops
but simply bishop g5 check king to d7
now the bishop moves and morphy would
have a bishop in the knight for a rook
in a completely pretty much winning
position for white so uh instead after
this
knight the d2 idea anderson continues
with his original plan that is knight to
e2 with check
and here we have king to f2 now morphe
is asking what are you going to do now
well anderson grabs the bishop with
check now king captures an e2
and now queen to g5 so again
what are you gonna do here uh maybe some
queen to g to check is possible uh maybe
the bishop is coming to h6 maybe the
threat and the knight on d2 uh it
doesn't look all that promising but you
know morphy still has to be very careful
that his king is on e2 so here rook
eight to e1 morphy of course brings his
last rook into the uh into the center of
the board and then he's gonna hide his
king king to d1 king to c1 and so on uh
anderson continues with bishop to h6 now
threatening queen captures here uh and
now queen to d5 uh offering a queen
trait and just defending the knight here
so
morphy is defending the entire game
but uh anderson is
well isn't really leaving him any choice
so here anderson tries one last trick
and that is rook to e8 with check saying
okay if you capture my rook i'm going to
capture your queen but morphy just says
king to d1 and he was in this position
on move 19 that adult anderson resigned
game one and uh morphy starts with a
lead in the second match uh so different
than in the first match where anderson
started with the lead and now morphy
starts with a lead uh but this was um uh
it was simply too too brief of a game
and it was too crushing i think anderson
understands that okay i lost the first
match now this second match even if i
win it it's not going to mean as much as
the first match since the first match
was the official match i can at least
try to create some sort of a brilliancy
that might be you know published
everywhere you know in the in the chess
world and i think this is uh what uh
what happened here but there are more
fine games so you know
you know we will check all of them out
five more left uh so stay tuned for that
and here you resign because you're
already down material uh the rook is
under attack the queen is under attack
there's not much you can do here if you
trade here once for example captures
captures uh again not not much to be
done here there is no check useful check
that you can give here so you might as
well trade here captures captures and
now you are down a whole piece so of
course completely winning for morphe
uh so
uh this is game one of their second
match hope you guys enjoyed it very
brief only 19 moves but uh you know such
such were the times uh so once again
hope you guys enjoyed it uh i would like
to thank tom darrell happy birthday will
simon novak gordon gottman and harry
walk for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot to really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga until it ends
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day